قانون عمره 100 عام استخدم لمحاكمه
الجواسيس والمسربين ويشكل خطرا قانونيا
كبيرا على رئيس الامريكي السابق قضايا
سابقه عده لقانون التجسس تشكل علامات
تحذير ترامب احدثها ما حصل مع الكولونيل
روبرتشن الذي تهم باساءه التعامل مع وثائق
السريه فضابط المخابرات تحمل المسؤوليه
كامله وتعاون مع المحققين على عكس رمب
فانخفضت عقوبته وحكم بالسجن لمده ثلاث
سنوات وفقا ما ذكرته
منذ خمس سنوات تم تسجيل حوالي اثنتي عشره
محاكمه جنائيه لاشخاص يحتفظون بمعلومات
سريه او معلومات دفاع وطني وفقا لوزاره
العدل في العديد من هذه القضايا تلقى
المتهمون احكاما طويله بالسجن بينهم
الموظفان السابقان في وكاله الامن القومي
هارولد مارتن وهو وحكم بالسجن سنوات وخمس
سنوات تباعا بعدها كما حكم في ابريل
الماضي على رقيب سابق في القوات الخاصه
بالسجن سبع سنوات وثلاثه اشهر بسبب
الاحتفاظ بمعلومات سريه بالاضافه الى
جرائم اخرى اذكروا انها المره الاولى التي
يتم فيها اتهام رئيس سابق ارتكاب انتهاك
نهائيا فيدرالي لكن كانت هناك حالات سابقه
لملاحقات
لسياسيين تضمنت مزاعم جنح وليست جنايه
كانت تتعلق بانتهاك قانون التجسس لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات